so making ribs pop culture and work with
PBS Digital Studios we don't average
five hundred thousand eight times here
hi I'm Ryan I my channel is pimp the
whip I do comedy sketches and i'm signed
at the network big fingers hi I'm
America young um i have my own children
died just launched but most of my work
is with other channels most specifically
recently Stanley's channel and comedy
which is basically funnier guy for women
those are my two main things from the
last couple of years which one the one
funny or die for comedy but yeah comedy
if how many subscribers since I haven't
like just thousands and thousands and
thousands of the idol I don't remember I
actually should know those numbers but i
think it's fiber about okay i know you
can use America Young America young yeah
so now you have a very interesting story
you you went to Stanford which is sort
of close to my heart because I grew up
there and I couldn't ever get into
Stanford but I used to work there so do
you want to tell us how you began and
sort of why you started posting videos
on YouTube sure yeah I was um it was my
senior of college and I was really
looking for a way to procrastinate
outside of Facebook
I would spend countless hours on there
looking at videos and Facebook could
just come out with their posted items
feature which is not length and I
thought would be really cool to sort of
make a comedy mockumentary about what it
is to be black at Stanford and post it
on Facebook and I'd like cast on my
friends as actors and because they're so
vain they'd be forced to be posted in
the new year spread the word and so it
did you know at the end I we got to do
three episodes it's really sporadic it
was like when I felt like it when I
didn't want to do homework and by the
end like I got people from Duke and you
know Howard in Georgetown saying oh my
god this is my experience crazy so I
really just liked the interactive
element of the web and then I decided
after two years later I moved back to LA
and decided to take web series seriously
and really tried to make it like a
television showing that i would post it
every week at the same time and you know
actively try to market it really be
consistent with my output and then by
the third web series I'm a black girl I
was able to learn from the mistakes of
my other series what was the span of
time Lisa know how long did it take
another you talk about learning from 3d
in a 23 back series when posted my first
youtube video in 2006 and it was like a
music video called funky and then
um the latest is 2012 so it's about five
years and five years but i would i would
say three years of serious close
rear
let's go on down line in terms of a
little bit about you a little bit more
about your youtube channel and also what
why you started doing this in the first
place why start posting videos on
YouTube
so we started we posted our first video
on YouTube together September 12 of last
year and we're having a big party
September 12 this year one year
anniversary well no it's okay and we had
to sort of seem you're both interested
in both filmmakers both went to film
school you both have MS BAE degrees that
are very useful and and and we were both
interested in this idea of building a
brand building a fan base getting you
know your work seen the
and so we look to a lot of people who
are already on YouTube with some what
they were doing and we thought oh no
we're too old because everybody on
YouTube is a teenager who watches
YouTube and that's probably fairly true
to a certain extent but we just started
making these videos and what you really
wanted to build up this brand build up
this book build up build up some sort of
online community and
that's basically led to us working with
PBS which they found us a month after we
started there's a site called it stats
bit stats XCOM where it basically breaks
down YouTube analytics and see
like popular channels like a lot of
views it's really useful for people who
are sort of more on the business and I
guess of YouTube looking at it as a
business reasons so we put an ad up
there
like 10 bucks there
the channel logo will be featured on the
front page basically found us because
one of our videos was like sort of
trending on there but I really don't
believe them because you really don't
have that many views and then we were
sort of in touch with them and it was a
really long process we finally site a
contract with them this year and so
they've been putting out some sub videos
like mr. Rogers we're next Bob Ross
remix and for us it's it's it's really
it's really been doing it for a year and
we're really excited about how far we've
been able to come in the past year but
we're very very new to this relatively
speaking
and we have a long way to go to monetize
even get more than like a thousand years
I don't know if you meant just like what
your this map is about yes it's the
channels called National Film Society
it's a two of us and we talk about
movies filmmaking a pop culture we
sometimes do we did like our first video
is called film school or no film school
so we talked about that topic we also
took a trip to Sundance and two
interviews with filmmakers actors to
various things mostly about filmmaking
and how you know being a filmmaker
people think it's really cool but it
really is not that great
it's nuts yeah di d st 80s and x time
and just real quick steven can you touch
on when you say not that many views can
you just put a break a shirt so we have
about 60 videos on our channel right now
and we acquire close to getting we're
like a 196,000 total views cool so we
average about usually it's like about a
thousand fifteen hundred views of video
is it only videos on the comedy podcast
wait okay yeah well we'll keep the
moving Brian jump in here bro I studied
film at UC Santa Cruz and one summer in
1999 I was an intern at a website that
was going to be the first network
television thing on the internet so it's
planted in my head that internet is the
way to go and then after that 2003 had
my own website where i was posting my
own comedy videos and i ran into a
friend at chatham 101 I don't know if
they're familiar with channel I was like
a comedy website or they have
competitions and my friend it was a
keeper Schaefer he was a also a student
at santa cruz with me in the film
program and he was like oh i just got
this big asian and i was like oh man
hook me up with that aging he's like oh
I just had this audition with Ben
Stiller was crazy Wow okay this is the
way to go the internet is the way to go
and then YouTube came out and I just
started doing it and I started getting
featured on there and I got featured on
the homepage of myspace but this is
before is monetized so all these views
that I was getting wasn't getting any
money for it but now it's monetized and
I'm like okay this is what I supposed to
be doing because all my friends are
making a living off of this stuff and
some of them are making six figures
which is it contain
and I side with the network because now
it's really hard to have your own
channel just by yourself I'm succeed you
need a network and the whole YouTube
thing has changed where it's just fall
into networks I'm really nervous this is
weird right now so let's expand on that
rise what do you mean network can you
can you get a bit more specific yeah or
two there there's a few of them
machinima is the biggest one
I'm saying the big frame they all have
different business models there's
breaker makers other huge one and
there's the collective full screen bunch
of it and so what they do is they take
the big channels and they bring it into
their network and they think the
different business models would be like
sharing the profit and helping you with
equipment whenever and what are you can
see exactly that so what are you getting
from the network that you weren't
getting on your own basically the
network that I'm with is just gives me a
higher CPM higher at advertising and
that they helping with the videos in any
sense are they saying like this is the
kind of content you need to be producing
are they yeah they I mean I can talk to
whatever I want and I can tell me like
these are my ears and it'll point me in
the right direction and make you help me
with collaborations and things like that
implement that works
so that's like a support system as well
and when they get opportunities for
advertising like in video they can throw
in our way and stuff like that but then
I met with other other places and the
same sort of thing and then this one
just seemed like the right one like one
of me and my friend tay zonday commander
thank you Ron get a question per person
in the back I said network the drunk
what's that big frame frame you
let's hear about to America okay I'm
trying to remember how it started it's
all one big blur of when um when
intended so I guess it all started
around the writers strike and when the
inertia just kind of came to a halt and
I had all this creative stuff i needed
to do so i started to i looked at my
resources and i was up live a garage i
can shoot in what can i make that takes
place in a garage how about group
therapy okay so i created a web series
that i shot with my friends just for fun
and didn't really bother promoting it um
I did it on my own website not on
youtube and I don't recommend that
because I think the powers have been
guarded YouTube and already that
established network is so much more
valuable than doing it on your own with
their own player on your own website and
then soon after I was asked to work with
their jerry zucker on his web channel
called national banana jerry zucker did
airplane and naked gun and some other
things so the fact that he was due I
just did it for fun I didn't think there
was any future it and then the fact that
he was on the web maybe go oh hold on he
couldn't knows what he's doing and so
getting to work with those guys was
amazing and then it's just one thing led
to another and then I was working on the
guild and all these other projects that
were being really successful doing
really really well and we're setting all
their own formats and then from all that
work from all these various projects i
was working on and they weren't mine I
got hired by comedy but a new content
acquisitions and production and then
while I was working for comedy eva i
created a show called geek therapy which
they got license I Stanley so it was
just this big it's such a small world it
really is the internet
fast that's not and everybody seems so
interconnected and I think the overall
drive behind it which is so exciting is
that this need to create this sense of
empowering not sitting back and waiting
for someone to call you but like I want
to make something and I want to make it
now and I'm going to share it with the
world and hope the world likes it but i
really liked making it so that's what
matters so that's kind of my convoluted
history I'm sure I left some stuff out
at that time I don't all of this you
know I want to touch on something here
and then something that you've taught
you that you've just touched on their
America is you know we've already even
as we began the panel you know people
coming in saying you know I really want
to learn how to monetize YouTube now
that energy going to start putting
videos on YouTube thinking i wanna i
want to make money from YouTube is that
was that the starting point I just
started that I went behind the curve on
that one what they clarify you weren't
in it you were just in it just because
you had to because you wanted create I
just guy yeah I started off just that I
wanted to make stuff and then I started
to see how much power how much money is
in it and power also because shows
you're being picked up there i know that
i have a friend tours over at Fox and
there's a whole department whose sole
job is to scour the internet for talent
that's what they do all day is just wash
if that's the farm team now for the
networks I'm to find writers and and
shows and stuff like that so it's it's a
different page it's a water
um I started off wanting to make videos
but then I started taking web series
little seriously I really thought there
would be an opportunity to monetize some
way whether there is enough sponsors
people a large following we'd be able to
like bring in France maybe to sponsor us
help us to make more videos things like
that but and then that the goal was to
try to do a web series of transition to
television which I quickly found out
that you shouldn't do if you're going to
make web videos make them for the web
don't try to bake stuff for the web to
go to television because it just doesn't
work web is web team is to make a
different story it's a completely
different story something absolutely and
so you know we tried that like I think I
got to about 10,000 views for per
episode for my second web series and it
still wasn't like people still weren't
really picking up so I was like my
friends are right there is no money in
web series but because the platforms
like IndieGoGo and Kickstarter which was
really really helpful to us you know you
can you can make you can monetize your
series in so many different ways
why you know how films on you guys want
to touch on did you start with one of
the business mindset or we're gonna
we're going to get this to a point we're
going to make money was that was that
like really a few in fact or motivating
factor or was it just there's something
in me where I have to make these videos
and active release them into server I
have a friend who works in machinima
some one of these networks and couple
friends wouldn't used to work there and
you know I read the story of like you
know we get these pieces it's friendly
machinima said we get these phone calls
from parents who call up michela they
say what is machinima and why are they
sending my 13 year old to check for ten
thousand dollars well I would love
$10,000 never made that much from film
my life and so um my friend who was
really encouraging these and you know
there's a lot of people who don't have
any filmmaking skills we're doing really
really well on youtube and you know
somebody who knows what they're doing
there's an opportunity there and so I
think what we quickly realized though or
not quickly slowly realize was that our
views are so low that it's like I mean
in actuality to make a decent living I
think you need like a million
use a month aggregate like all your
videos if you're getting a million views
a month you can make a decent living on
youtube from that coma ads we're like
nowhere near that and so for us you know
we would like to make a living
continuing to make content for the web
but you know some but for now it's like
okay it's if it's not going to be your
youtube how do we do so we're looking at
other ways such as merchandise we're
actually going to be doing a web series
which we're going to be launching
kickstarter for next month
and other ways to reach out to the
people who the families that we do have
and using that as hopefully as a
springboard to more people fighting this
and continuing to grow
when I first got involved in it was just
to make stuff cuz I needed to make stuff
and I already had a website where i was
making stuff that nobody was seeing it
so i looked at as a way to grow with
fanbase then then I just started making
stuff for my fans and I didn't really
think I was gonna get paid paid for it
it's a nice
but also because my friend akiva
schaffer he got this huge manager and
went on to Saturday Night Live with the
lonely island and all this stuff it's
just like okay well I can use it to
maybe get an agent or manager and that
sort of thing promote projects and
working on
requesting a lot of people here
interested monetization but I thought I
heard some contradictory things
like you said no money
Wow
there's been money in it for me because
I worked for people who had money that's
a little bit different than making it on
our own if you're getting a lots of
numbers and it's basically CPM so it's
based on how many clicks you get on your
video it's pretty simple math I don't
know it so well because I have made a
lot of money through that I just like I
said I just started on the full screen
it's the network my mom but the but it's
basically however many clicks you get is
how much you get and like we're talking
like point zero one cent per click we're
not talking a dollar per click so
there's that way of making money and
then then there's and there's different
ones of you have a banner at the bottom
you'll get a certain amount of money and
then you have opportunities to make
commercials basically like videos for
certain new shows coming out they'll say
all right well pay twenty dollars per
CPM or something but then they're not
usually interesting so you're usually
not getting that many views on that I
think she probably the best one to talk
to you about actual monetization because
I'm still it's still quagmire for me
you feel comfortable rusty I mean right
yes